the way that it's functioning at the
times but i could say the same about
publishing houses or hollywood studios
or
big tech corporations is that
the people at the top are living in
tremendous fear of a minority and i
don't mean
racial minority or gender minority but a
minority constituency
inside the paper who do not believe
in the historical mission of the
[Music]
institution
hello and welcome to trigonometry
i'm francis foster i'm constantine
kitten and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
a fascinating person we have for you
today she is an american author
journalist and as a very recently
podcaster barry weiss welcome to
trigonometry thank you guys so much for
having me
oh it's a real pleasure to have you on
the show uh for anyone who's not
familiar
with you your backstory your background
who you are just tell everybody a little
bit about
about that how have you managed to end
up here talking to us
i don't know i'm a jew from pittsburgh
uh that's kind of the long and short of
it uh i was born
in the jewish community of squirrel hill
um
oldest of four children uh four
daughters
i'm from a politically mixed marriage my
dad is
a trump curious conservative my mom is a
liberal
she withheld sex during the 2016 and
2020 elections to make sure that
he would vote in the right way which i
think meant writing in steph curry
uh the first time around and maybe like
nikki haley the second time
so it was effective um and you know
that was my background i i come from a
family and i think this is relevant to
kind of where i wound up because i never
imagined i would be a writer
where arguing about things and
disagreeing about things and talking
about big ideas
was totally natural and normal and it
was also normal
to vehemently disagree with people that
you love the most
in your life and that in the end of the
day you know you still
still you still love them so i think
that's one virtue that my parents gave
me that i feel like is
in incredibly short supply these days in
my country and i know yours too
so from there go to columbia university
um long story short i
was pretty active when i was a college
student
politically on the subject of israel but
also
wound up start being a columnist for the
student paper and starting my own
uh publication that's still in existence
and
through a serendipitous event i was
debating the college socialists i
believe
um this older gentleman was at the
debate very clearly not an undergraduate
and he told me that his name was charles
stevens and his son brett stevens worked
at the wall street journal i had never
read the wall street journal i thought
it was only an economics newspaper
and that i should meet him and i should
go be an intern there and that was
really
it that's that was my first sort of
foray into professional journalism
i spent basically the past decade
at the wall street journal tablet
magazine a jewish magazine that's
excellent
and and the new york times and i think
the relevant thing for
people who have never heard of me is
that i
went from being the sort of leftmost
flank of a conservative editorial page
at the wall street journal
where i was very regularly told that i
was a squish and a pushover and
um to the new york times where i was
something like the right to the right of
attila the hun
and i think in a way that journey um is
not
in any way unique to me i think it kind
of tells a broader story
about um where the country's going
um maybe even more broadly where the
west is going
in terms of more extremist polarized
politics and certainly it tells the
story about where the mainstream media
is which is increasingly
a choice between two increasingly stark
options
the last thing i'll say that i think is
probably relevant is that
um i became a bat mitzvah
at tree of life synagogue in pittsburgh
which
people may or may not remember was the
site of the deadliest attack on jews in
american history
in october 27 2018 where a neo-nazi
walked into the synagogue and killed 11
people um that moment
it's hard to summarize in a quick sound
bite but that moment was pretty
impactful on my life and i wound up sort
of putting to the side the book that i
was supposed to write about the culture
war
i'm hoping to pick that up soon and i
ended up writing a book called how to
fight anti-semitism
so that's also why i would think a
really important piece of my
my journey over the past few years um
and then
the last thing i'll say is that um my
most
recent job was that you know i had kind
of the plum job
in all of journalism i was an op-ed
writer and editor
at the new york times like i mentioned
and i chose to leave that of my own
accord which my grandma is still sort of
scratching her head about
so um that's where i am now i now i'm a
newspaper woman without a newspaper i
have a newsletter
um and now increasingly like lots of
uh people in this country and all over i
have a podcast like you guys so
that's that's kind of the big picture
yeah and it's called honestly with barry
vice i'm looking forward to seeing some
of the stuff that's coming up because
you've only just started it
uh but listen the reason we wanted to
talk to you
most of all we'll probably come back to
the anti-semitism but
we wouldn't be doing this show if
journalism
hadn't become what it's become right
now you've been on the inside
yes i have what is happening to
journalism
and newspapers and the mainstream media
okay well let's start with two things
the first thing is a radical shift in
the economic model
of how newspapers how television
stations
how radio makes money
go back to the age before the internet i
know it's very hard to do that but
back in the day some 20 years ago the
constituency that the new york times had
to please the constituency that they had
to worry about
pissing off and i'm talking about the
new york times is a stand-in for all
publications
pretty much in the legacy press that
constituency was advertisers
right that's who they had to worry about
well that's no longer the case the
advertising model as we know has
collapsed
and the model now is subscribers well if
you go and you look
at who are the people that subscribe to
the new york times
it's something like 95 percent identify
as progressive
or liberal or you know not old-school
democrat but democrat
so if the
goal right is to keep your subscribers
engaged
to keep them happy it only makes sense
that the thing that you would feed them
is their version of political heroine
which in the case of the new york times
meant donald trump is a moral monster
et cetera et cetera et cetera et cetera
and that
model if you go look at the stock price
um and you look at the subscriber
numbers
is working beautifully but what's good
for business may not be good for
democracy so that thing that i just
described to you
it's the same model at fox where
obviously it's the diametric opposite in
terms of who the audience is but that's
again the goal is to keep people engaged
keep people engaged
now the second thing that comes on top
of that is
um is social media and social media
amplifies this trend
because what it does is that it gives or
maybe not gives a microphone i was going
to say there's a group of people that
tend to hog the microphone
that tend to be the most extremist part
of that base and that then gives editors
and reporters a sense of oh wow
that's what they want and what happens
is
and it's much more insidious than a kind
of like top down
do this which is i think how people
maybe imagine it from the outside
it's much more subtle because we are
like you know we're we're animals right
we we respond well
to incentives and if the if you know
that writing about a certain topic or
writing about a certain topic from a
particular perspective
or telling your readers who feel a
certain way that you know because you're
getting constant feedback about it
that they feel a certain way about the
world you naturally want to just
please them because pleasing them means
winning for yourself
it means going viral it means being most
popular inside the paper
it means you know getting better
assignments and on and on and on
so that's the other thing that's going
on i would say the third thing that's
going on that's related to it
is what's been talked about is the kind
of ideological takeover
of 20th century institutions that are
meant to uphold the liberal order
and are increasingly betraying their
mission
and betraying their values in order to
pursue a very different kind of ideology
that's not liberal at all and so
that is very much what i witnessed when
i was at the new york times
the vast majority i still believe of
people at the new york times
still believe in the old school liberal
model of journalism what do i mean by
that
things that we used to take for granted
you know pursuing the truth
telling it whether or not it's
convenient to a particular political
constituency
striving for objectivity even though we
all recognize that there's no such thing
as the view from nowhere and that we're
all incredibly subjective
um you know vying to be the the paper of
record
all the news that's fit to print that
has given way to something
much more morally and politically
strident
um some journalists have referred to
this without irony as being
journalism in the service of moral
clarity now
who whose morals they are and who has
the clarity right
is is the whole question and they
believe that they do and so
the way that it's functioning at the
times but i could say the same about
publishing houses or hollywood studios
or big
tech corporations is that the people at
the top
are living in tremendous fear of a
minority and i don't mean racial
minority or gender minority but a
minority constituency
inside the paper who do not believe
in the historical mission of the
institution
and so rather than although we have some
good examples of this that maybe we'll
get to
rather than saying to those people hey
if you believe that
words are violence hey if you believe
that an op-ed by a sitting
united states senator literally puts
people's lives in danger
maybe journalism isn't the right career
for you instead they find themselves
being struggle sessioned
in full view of thousands of employees
right because the whole thing is that
people are i i've i knew this to be true
but i really feel it now in a visceral
way now that i've witnessed it over and
over and over again
people generally act in heard
they do not want to stick their necks
out the most painful thing is the idea
of being
kicked out or ostracized from your
community especially
if the way your community is branding
itself
especially the way your community is
identifying itself is like the community
of the good and the righteous and the
right side of history
the worst thing ever would be to be told
that you're not
on that right side the worst thing ever
would be to be told
that you're a bigot or you're an ism or
you're a phobe
in some kind of way and so what you have
and this is
really the key the cowardice at the top
of these institutions
is what's allowing for all of this to
take place because if the people that
were actually in charge were courageous
and said no politely and no we'll give
you severance but this isn't the right
place for you
or maybe no we're not going to hire you
in the first place if you don't believe
that an op-ed page in my case
should share the range of views that
represents the truth about the country
that you live in
the whole thing would be playing out
quite differently
it it's very very interesting that you
said that
and one of the things i kept thinking
barry when you were explaining their
business models
what was going off in my head is but
you're just creating large echo chambers
that's all you do that's all of us are
creating and what effect is that having
on society
i mean we're all living in it right
we're living in different
epistemological realities
where if you watch you know laura ingram
and sean hannity
i'm not sure what the exact comparison
in england would be but
we don't have anything quite like that
here it's coming i'm sure but not yet
you know versus like if you watch rachel
maddow every night you just have a
totally different perception of what's
going on in the country
that's problem number one problem number
two is like
if is is and i think we're all feeling
this in our lives
the feeling of like being motivated by
fear
rather than empathy and understanding
and being
increasingly told that we need to be
really really scared
of the opposite tribe that somehow wants
to fundamentally undo
the foundation of the country i mean
that's ultimately what it's about and so
those fissures are obvious not just in
society at large but i think sometimes
in friend groups and in families and in
people's own lives
and i i just think that it's
extraordinarily dangerous
it betrays my most fundamental values
that i believe in
and ultimately that's why i decided to
self-deport
from you know the highest purchase of
american journalism
because i just didn't want to be part of
that machine
and it seemed to me quite clear and i
mean this in a non-judgmental way that
it really does work as a business model
just like facebook stoking outrage
really does work as a business model i
do not think that someone has yet come
up
with the solution to this in terms of
like
economics because this clearly works
it's clearly tapping into some part
of our lizard brain you know that wants
to keep hitting the pellet and getting
the
the sugar but i want to be part
um of trying to see if there's a better
way
and you talk about if there's a better
way and you use terms of
progressive liberal on the left
now at one point these were how i
described myself
i was a teacher for many years yeah i
look at these labels and i don't
feel and i don't i feel as if i couldn't
be more
ostracized from them would you be able
to explain to our
listeners and to our viewers what these
terms used to mean
what they mean and what they mean now
so when i identify myself as a liberal
and i think when a lot of people
identify themselves as liberals
until quite recently what they mean was
this
liberalism is not a partisan term
liberalism is a view of the world that
holds the following truths
that we're all created the in the image
of god whether or not you believe in god
but we act that way that because of that
equality in a cosmic sense we're all
entitled to
equal treatment and equality under the
law
that no person should be
guilty for the sins of their their
parents
that no person because of their skin
color because of other immutable
characteristics
should be held to a standard of
collective innocence or collective guilt
because of it
the idea that we judge people based on
their actions based on their character
and based on their merit
and not based on um qualities of their
identity
the idea that we're not constrained to
the lane of our birth
that's really important the idea that
because we're a particular identity it
doesn't mean that we can't understand
or strive to understand someone from a
different group
and the idea perhaps most importantly
that politics is not the only thing in
life
and that there are things that fall
outside of the realm of politics and
those are the most important things in
life
art music love relationships
family and that not everything needs to
be put to political litmus tests
if you believe that you believe in the
liberal worldview
and you can be a conservative liberal or
you could be a liberal liberal but that
by and large is what i think we mean
when we're talking about the liberal
worldview that is now being challenged
and it's very obviously being challenged
by
the far right right the blood and soil
ethnonationalist
people marching in charlottesville
shouting jews will not replace us
that's the obvious threat to liberalism
from the right
we don't need to have a debate about
that threat
everyone who's sane sees the evil
of that worldview um and frankly
the mainstream media pays an incredible
amount of attention
to that worldview and so i think that
it's you know it's like when someone
marches down the street
shouting jews will not replace us or
says jews need to die or says
you know some people because of their
skin color are less american than others
like
there's no moral debate about what that
is the confusion i think
and the reason that so many are caught
flat-footed by the challenge to
liberalism from the far left is it
become it doesn't
have a tiki torch it comes cloaked
in the language and in the garments of
social justice
of progress of civil rights of being on
the right side of history and all the
things that liberals
want to be a part of but if you look
under the hood
beyond the slogans of what this
movements these movements and this
ideology
that doesn't really have a name yet some
call it wokeness some call it
soft totalitarianism some call it
critical social justice
um the critic wesley yang has called it
the successor ideology because it is
trying to be
the successor to liberalism i think
that's a really effective term
it's really this stew of
supremely unenlightened ideas
um that try and replace you know
persuasion with public shaming that try
and say that no
you know we're determined by the
circumstances of our birth
that we're pitted in a sort of war
against all
of identity group versus identity group
and it's sort of a zero-sum
battle in which we're all vying for the
most claims to victimhood because what
what accrues power to you
what the way that we judge the things
that come out of your mouth and the
truth claim
is not the actual content but the sub
but but your identity the more
victimhood you can claim the literally
the more claim you have to morality and
truth
um it claims that we actually do have
collective innocence
or collective guilt it claims that we
are guilty for the sins of our fathers
in so many ways if you just look at what
these people say
not necessarily the people that are
hanging up the sign in the window right
who want to to who are doing it for
well-intentioned reasons but the
hardcore of this ideology
it is just deeply deeply liberal and the
reason that i feel like it's the battle
of our lifetime to resist it
is because it has captured
so many of the institutions including
journalism
that we rely on to sort of tell us the
truth about the world
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be
my old wallet was massive so it brought
all the ladies to the yard which was a
huge distraction
and got in the way of my esteemed work
on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you
this is mine sleek stylish and with an
industrial look to it
you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using
a clip like this one or a strap we've
got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anton has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his
on the black market the great thing
about ridge is that they give you a
lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet
for the rest of your life ridge are so
confident in the quality of their
product
they will give you 45 days to test drive
their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days
because ridge are such great guys
they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns
to take advantage of this incredible
offer go to rich.com
forward slash trigger that's ridge.com
forward slash trigger
and use our special code which is of
course trigger
barry we'll talk about the institutional
capture in a second but first of all i
feel like
there is a contradiction in the
conversation we're having because on the
on the one hand
we lament the increasing polarization of
society where
we are all deeply suspicious of quo
unquote the other side and instead of
seeing them
as people we disagree with we now see
them as the people who are
you know that they want to destroy
america or destroy
the british way of life or whatever but
on the other hand
i also agree with what you've just said
where you know the far right
obviously we all understand that that is
not compatible with
with the world that we want to live in
but but this other thing
i mean it is about destroying the
foundations of the western world so
well what i mean the thing that these
that both of these ideologies have in
common
is that they're manikin and binary and
they split the world into good and bad
right black and white oppressed and
oppressor and anything
any ideology that does that cannot be
harmonized with the liberal project yeah
i agree
i agree my point my point is we lament
the media
polarizing us and making us think that
the other people
who we don't agree with are the enemies
of in our case western civilization
but at the same time i think it's also
accurate to say that there are some
people
who are the enemies of western
civilization do you see the the
contradiction i'm getting at
i do i i i i do see that contradiction
and i guess i would say that
i it's the job of anyone that wants to
fight
for the liberal project broadly defined
to stand up against both of those things
wherever they rear their head i think
the problem in the mainstream
is that you have one group of people
relentlessly insisting that it's just
this one group
and if you only watch that you think
it's just this one group
but then if you watch the other side
it's the opposite case
and i think what's required right now of
those of us who
want to still live in a reality-based
world those of us in the reality-based
community
that it's our obligation to talk about
both i think one thing that
critics sort of hit me with is the idea
that i focus inordinately on the threat
from the far left
and i do focus more on that the reason
for that is not because i don't take the
threat from the far right seriously
like i said earlier i mean i'm from a
community where i witnessed
the evil of what that ideology is about
so i take it extremely seriously and it
had an impact on my own life
but i think that like there are giant
news organizations
focusing all of their time and energy on
that threat
and there's very few people that are
focusing on the other one and so that's
one of the reasons that i try and put a
special emphasis there
it'd be interesting because this is
something that we have a bit of an issue
with as well i suppose we focus a lot
on some of the issues to do we focus on
both sides but particularly the far left
not necessarily because of what you've
said but rather
certainly in my i don't know where
francis would agree with this but my
view
while the far right is obviously evil
and obviously a threat
i just don't see the same level of
public support i don't see the same
level of the willingness to
legitimize some of the ideas of the far
right in the mainstream discourse i
don't see the numerical support in terms
of
the number of people who buy into this
ideology
i don't see far-right narratives being
shoved down my throat on radio and
television and newspapers etc
so do you feel like these threats are
equally dangerous i i think that they
it's always a really hard question to
answer because they have
like um parasitics the wrong word but
they
they are like they have a co-dependent
relationship
in this moment constantine i i agree
with you
that i think the threat from the far
left has
just inordinately more power in the
culture
but the problem right is that what the
backlash to that
is going to be and the way that it's
going to empower
the kind of ethno-nationalist neo-nazi
right
is one of the reasons that i am so
scared
about what's coming out of the far left
because i just like if you just look out
into the world
you see the way that this dynamic is
playing out and it
really really worries me if this thing
continues to sort of
sweep through the culture without
resistance what is going to come in
response to it
so that is one of the reasons that i
feel like it's so incredibly urgent
and why do you think barry we don't see
the far left as a problem
because constantine's uh family are from
the soviet union i have family from
venezuela
you know we've seen what the far left
has done to our respective countries
but in the uk in you know in america i
see kids walking around with che guevara
t-shirts you know abolish capitalism
why is that
i thought about this so much i think
there are two reasons
one has to do with maybe institutional
capture before we called it that which
is to say
most people educated in this country you
learn
a tremendous amount i would say because
i went to a jewish day school it was
different
and we had tons of students who were
from the former soviet union and so
i was aware of what that meant because
it was like
in my family like that was in our
community that was something oh why are
these people moving here okay let's
understand what actually happened there
but were it not for that and a lot of
extremely well-educated people i know
who went to some of the best prep
schools in the country
really don't learn about the evils of
soviet communism for example at all
so that's one aspect of it there's just
genuine ignorance
and i think the other thing is like just
better branding like if your thing is
about
um you know lifting up everyone equally
doesn't that sound great you know if
your thing
is about like guaranteeing everyone
whatever we we all know the promises
like i think there's
that that still resonates maybe for
people who
believe it hasn't been tried yet you
know or hasn't been tried yet in the
right way it's amazing to me that that's
the reality
but i think that for a lot of young
americans
that is just the reality and frankly
like just look at popular culture like
other than mr jones you know that movie
that came out recently or maybe the
lives of others
like is there anything that gets made
that shows
the evils of i'm just thinking now about
like what
like stalinism and the former survey
like is there anything about that
not really there's a ton about
fascists as there should be but i think
i think that's a that's a huge part of
it is just like this
tremendous gap in people's education
um yeah i wish i had a better answer but
but i i'm constantly running into this
from people that i
think of as being very sophisticated
and extraordinarily well-educated
and do you think i think part of it
barry is that
capitalism isn't really working for a
lot of people
particularly young people in in the uk
you can see it with the housing market
it doesn't matter how much you earn it
doesn't
matter how good your job is you're never
going to get on the housing ladder
unless you've got
mum and dad to support you it just seems
the
wages are stagnating whilst everything
is getting more expensive
do you think that might be the problem
people are looking around and going well
this isn't working
i think that's a huge aspect of it
especially i don't know how old you guys
are but i imagine we're similar 23.
me too so we're similar age yeah yeah
yeah
so we're similar um we're one year older
than you
yeah okay cool so as elder millennials
uh i think that we know
like you know think about what our
generation's lived through and here it's
been you know the great recession
the crushing student debt crisis the
fact that like basic
tenants of what used to be called
unironically the american dream
are totally out of reach for people in
my generation and so
absolutely i think that capitalism has
been
you know beaten down and and has
under understandably poor reputation
among people of our generation and
they're looking for
something better and i i just think that
the solution
is a much more serious
social safety net and policies that
lift up the poorest people in the
country um
obviously not communism but i think that
yeah the fact that capitalism has
failed for so many people has left them
understandably casting about
for something better do you not think
also i mean jonathan high obviously has
written quite a lot about the culture of
safety ism
and all of that you probably would have
seen while working
at the new york times younger the next
generation
we are actually there's a term for for
us which i always forget that generation
between millennials and the one before
like
something i can't remember whatever it's
basically the generation that didn't
have internet growing up
but did when they got to like 16 17 18 i
think yeah
but the next generation who always had
the internet
their values are all so different the
the the something happened there where
the focus on culture being offended
about things all of that stuff started
to come through
and performative caring and performative
compassion started
this my opinion anyway started to set in
did you notice a generational
shift in terms of the people coming
through into journalism for
in your experience yes but i think that
has maybe less to do with the internet
and more to do with
ideological capture of elite
universities here
right because this isn't every and
everyone problem this is mostly an elite
problem
the problem is is that the elites
control
all of the institutions in the culture
so like the good and the bad news right
is that
ideas really really matter and
the ideas that you're exposed to or not
exposed to
during the most formative years of your
intellectual development which is
college
like if all you're exposed to is this
broad view of the world that we've sort
of been circling here and you think that
disagreement is violence and you think
you know in the case of yale
university and nicholas and erica
christakis that emails about halloween
costumes
are literal violence or at evergreen
state college with you know two of my
heroes brett weinstein and heather heing
that
you know resisting a day of racial
segregation is somehow racist
and then all of a sudden you're going
into these institutions
right the old view of things was that
if you were you know a an anthro major
advancer or a gender studies major at
columbia
like you were exposed to some radical
politics sure
but you would go and get your job at jp
morgan or mckinsey at the new york times
or
now netflix or hbo max or whatever and
like
you would leave those ideas behind and
the institution would be so
strong that it would shape you rather
than you shaping it
but as uvalavin and others have put much
more articulately than me the opposite
has happened
the institutions have become platforms
first of all
rather than institutions and and rather
than them
shaping the young people coming up into
them
no the young people coming up into them
have shaped them
and one of the reasons they've been able
to do that so effectively
is that the quivers that they have are
so incredibly powerful
they wield you know the threat of moral
shaming
they wield the threat of cancellation
and they have this incredible thing
called twitter and facebook
to do it and so in a weird way
well i'll i'll sort of leave it at that
but did i see the generational divide
absolutely it's not it's it's
look speaking of the soviet union there
are double thinkers
okay and there are dissidents and those
are strange words to use
when you're living in america but that's
100 what's going on
and so it's really hard to figure out
exactly who believes what
right unless you're in like you know
in your basement reading your psalmist
or your equivalent with the people that
you really just you know that are super
high trust inside an institution
there are a lot of people that say one
thing in public
or say one thing in the slack channel
but then in a signal
text me something totally different yeah
we were talking about
this morning actually barry that we know
when a comedian or a journalist or a
public figure in the uk in this country
has decided they don't give a [ __ ] about
their careers when they follow us on
twitter that's when we know
they're done they're ready
i know people i heard a story about an
agent the other day who
got fired from her job for following a
conservative on twitter
i mean that's the level that we're
talking about so it's understandable
that people are scared and not telling
the truth
but the reason that i think it's hard to
figure out exactly who's true believers
or or who's just kind of going along
because they have children to support
and a family and a mortgage to pay it's
hard to suss that out but my feeling i'm
pretty confident
that it's still very much a minority
view
that's being supercharged by the younger
generation let's say the under 30
generation
but a lot of older people are going
along with it because they're saying
they're looking and seeing
same things going on in the democratic
party like oh the prevailing political
winds are at their backs
those people are gonna be my bosses one
day and it looks like the publisher of
the paper isn't standing up to them so
seems like the right thing to do would
be to go along with it and i think
that's a lot of what's happening
is just this kind of like people going
along with something
that they know is wrong thinking though
that if they just
accommodate in xyz ways if they just
apologize in the right way
if they just caveat this or that that it
will go away
and that is the delusion that's the
ultimate illusion
but it's like you said and i love the
way that you've used that word delusion
but like all delusions barry it's not
sustainable surely
you can't sustain a delusion can you
well
of course ultimately you can't sustain a
delusion the question is
how much is it going to burn through
before it before it dies out
and that the notion that i think a lot
of
people who are who know that this is bad
but are not saying so publicly
somehow believe that it's going to
recede on its own
without resistance and i think that's a
very dangerous view
and i think that it's incumbent on
people right now like i think it's
people's moral duty
to speak out about something that they
know is wrong
and the thing that i think is happening
is that it's like almost for the sake of
short-term comfort
people are sacrificing like
long-term the things that allow us to
even be able to speak out in the first
place
i don't really think most people
understand what we're at threat of
losing
and by the way i hope that someone's
gonna view this tape 10 years from now
and be like that lady was hysterical and
crazy
like i hope that i'm overstating it and
i hope that i'm wrong
but just watching what i've seen at the
new york times but just in my reporting
in
sectors like education k-12 and medicine
and the law i i don't i just don't think
that i'm overstating the case at least
in this moment
let's talk about that barry what are you
talking about what do we have to lose
what is happening education what is
happening in healthcare
you're an intelligent experienced
journalist you've seen many things
why are you concerned about what's
happening and what is it that you're
seeing
well what i'm seeing is people afraid to
tell the truth i'm seeing people that
are acting
based on fear including
doctors and lawyers and like
let's let me put it this way it's one
thing when a celebrity
you know says a lie on the internet
to protect their brand or because they
don't want to lose their sponsorship
or because they want china you know to
pick up their avengers movie
it is quite another thing when a doctor
who literally deals with matters of life
and death is unable to say things like
there are differences between males and
females or is unable to say
that you know certain groups of people
have more proclivities
towards certain diseases and that that
doesn't mean anything
about anyone's i like that
and acknowledging that so like that's
the kind of thing we've been
exposing um on my newsletter um in k
through 12 education what does it look
like and it looks like you know
throwing out classic books like to kill
a mockingbird or
huckleberry finn or tons of others that
i can name
um catcher in the rye and replacing them
with ibram kendi books um rather than
reading both as an example um it means
teaching children that their skin color
really really matters to them and their
skin color is an extremely important
part of who they are
rather than their character so what i'm
talking about
is what i what i articulated before the
liberal project
those ideas those values that allow
us to come on this and disagree in
public
or agree in public but have a
conversation and not tear each other's
throats out
that is what's under threat like
i i really believe that and that's
ultimately why i feel
like that's why i'm doing the work that
i'm doing because i want to expose what
i feel like a lot of journalists are
ignoring or actively lying about
because this thing that i'm describing
it's not going to be contained
you know to high-rises in midtown
manhattan
or harvard university or yale like
this is coming to affect everyone and
that's why it's so important for us to
stand up against it
and you say it's so important to stand
up against it but
isn't it a really tough ass to do if
someone's got a mortgage
they're reliant on a salary they've got
kids etc etc and knowing that they can
be cut at any moment
yes yes it is a hard ask
and not everyone can not everyone can
stand up to this or needs to stand up to
this
in exactly the same way right
it could be that you support
organizations like you know
the trigonometry like trigonometry
exactly
that's that's the name you were
searching for that's right or like my
sub stack or like there's this amazing
new organization i'm on the board of
fair the foundation against intolerance
and racism
there's so many things that you could do
quietly
but i would also suggest to people and
without sounding like too high-minded
about it
there are things worth sacrificing
professional advancement and prestige
for
and you know like
the things that might feel like major
sacrifices already in this moment
what is that going to look like a year
or two years or five years from now
if this thing continues to roll through
well western civilization
without good people people of conscience
standing up to it
i mean what do you think it's going to
look like barry i really hesitate that
question because i think we're going to
go down a pretty depressing alley but go
for it you love it
i don't know i'm miserable well wait
hold on you guys are closer to places
like
you know the soviet union and venezuela
what do you think it's going to look
like
oh if it's going to look like venezuela
it's going to be great we're all going
to lose weight barry
it's going to be we're going to be super
slim it's going to be great there's
going to be time on the beach
yeah we're going to be very equal we're
going to be equally poor
yeah that's going to be great so yeah
there's lots to look forward to but look
i i personally i agree with you that
i mean especially when you talk about
education
if you teach if you spend enough time
teaching the next generation and the one
after that
to think of themselves primarily through
their ethnicity and their skin color
in my opinion there's only one way that
ends
there's only one way that ends because
this is all this [ __ ] has been tried
before
again and again and again and given
particularly that we live in
multi-ethnic societies
uh you know there's only one way that
ends
well right and you i hope you guys saw
it but we just exposed this
you know there was a professor i did not
believe it when i first heard the tape
maybe we want to include it where you
know a psychiatrist delivering
grand rounds at yale university
openly fantasized about unloading a
revolver
into the brains of white people um who
talked about
how she fantasized about it and walked
away guiltless because she was doing a
favor to civ i mean
you have to listen to this to believe it
now you know how france's girlfriend
[Laughter]
feels
a revolver into the head of any wet
person that got in my way
gearing their body and raising my bloody
hands as i walked away relatively
differently
how has that become normalized the way
that's become normalized is that people
are not standing up to things that very
obviously
like are are wrong right you don't need
to
understand what critical race theory is
or have read
whatever like marcus or foucault to know
that a psychiatrist
at yale talking about murdering people
based on their race
is wrong and
like don't be if you're listening to
this
like don't be fooled by the jargon you
know
like it's it's common sense you know
that that's wrong
and the thing to do is not wait for the
cavalry to come in
like we're the cavalry like trigonometry
is the cavalry
so like you got to stand up you got to
speak out because
as hard as it feels now sorry to repeat
myself but like
as hard as it feels now if it already
feels hard
that's a sign to you that things are
already too far gone
it shouldn't be hard to stand up against
something like that
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website
well if you do then easy dns are the
company for you easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be council culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50 percent off with the
initial purchase
sign up for their newsletter access of
easy
that tells you everything you need to
know about technology
privacy and censorship
you say it shouldn't be hard to stand up
against something like that but we look
at
you know particularly you know the arts
entertainment
publishing all these industries seems to
have been toppled one
after another after another after
another and now it's infected sport
well what's happening right though is
and i i hope that we're gonna look back
on it this way
what's going on is is the rotting out of
20th century institutions
but what's happening and that's horrible
and deserves like i was heart sick about
it
for a long time but once you move beyond
the grieving process
you're like wait hold on joe rogan has
you know
more viewers and listeners on a single
episode
than all of cnn in a week like
i think the more people came true well
he had like oh i mean if you look at the
average ratings
of cnn's getting like something per
episode
per night something like post-trump
right
they're in the slump it's like something
like 300 000. it's it's a very very
low number right and like joe rogan with
dave chappelle had something like 50
million downloads
so it's like it's true that
like what you're saying is totally true
and i'm living in la and so now i'm
seeing a whole nother side of it out
here in hollywood
but what's also true is that people are
building new things
and like that's the whole game as far as
i'm concerned
if there are institutions that can be
salvaged and shored up we should do that
because it's really [ __ ] hard to
build new things
but otherwise all of our energy should
be going on
building new institutions and new
projects
new schools new universities new
publishing houses
new podcast networks etc etc etc
that uphold the values that we've been
talking about during this hour
and that are immunized to the
ideological takeover and that's the real
challenge
how to how to prevent yourself from
experiencing exactly what all of these
storied institutions are right now
yeah that's a really good point and i
and i hope that process is happening
because the more i look at
a lot not all but a lot of the
mainstream media the
the legacy institutions of various kinds
i just i just think they all need to
burn down to the ground to be honest
because
that that's what i'm seeing uh but look
let me put a counter argument here is
there a possibility that we are just a
bunch of slightly getting older bigots
now and we've just
you know we just don't like progress and
we hate gay people and we hate black
people and we just hate everyone
no i'm gay i know you are i know uh
you know and and secretly deep down you
and i hate the jews and
whatever you know what i mean like we're
just really regressive and we just hate
the fact that
the world yet again is moving forward
and finally it's recognizing
yet more minority groups that have been
marginalized and
and we're all really uncomfortable with
whatever is going on
what i would say to that is that if you
study american history
the thing that has allowed for the
american
experiment to come to include
you know it's pride month so we're
talking about gay marriage recently like
to come to include more and more groups
in its embrace to come to abolish
slavery to come to you know
pass this past civil rights law to
pass gay marriage and we can go through
tons of different examples
the tools that have allowed us to do
that
are the liberal tools and the tools
whatever you think of the founders moral
hypocrisy
the tools that the founders laid out in
the constitution and the bill of rights
that's why i know that this ideology
is dangerous because it basically says
we don't need those tools anymore
that because those tools were invented
by bigoted dead white men
we gotta we gotta tear the whole house
down rather than improving and renewing
and rebuilding
we're tearing down and that's how i know
that this is different because it's not
saying
let's think about who's been left out
let's think about who needs to be
included
let's think about who's you know yeah
everything i just said that's not what
it's asking
it's asking for a total teardown and
that's why i think
that you know we're not just cranky old
becoming middle-aged and graying people
that's why i think we're responding to
something quite real
and you say we're responding to
something quite real
do you think that the younger generation
are going to wake up or do you think
they're going to carry on as they have
been
i have to tell you i've been like
through the company i'm building and
other things i also have a sister who's
25.
and living in brooklyn and is the
antithesis of the kind of brooklyn
stereotype so
i have to say there's a lot of genzirs i
think that's the name of their
generation that i meet that i think are
incredible
and very much don't buy into this so
um i think i i'm actually feeling like
super optimistic when i felt pessimistic
was
when i was in the world of the new york
times and i was just like
this you know but but since i've left i
feel
first of all liberated and i feel like
oh wow
like i'm participating
to whatever small extent that i am in
doing the thing that i
i really believe is is being asked of us
in this moment in history which is
trying to build new things
that that live up to our values barry i
was going to ask you
uh slightly going back in terms of our
conversation but i think it's valuable
tell us what it was like you obviously
left the new york times
what was it like going into work in that
sort of environment day in doubt
the reason i'm asking you this is
because i i want you to give
people a flavor and i think a lot of
people would recognize
their own experience in it potentially
and then we can talk about what they can
sure
well as an unhinged zionist as my friend
andrew sullivan once called me
um you know i was never cool uh to begin
with
uh i you know i had had a career
beforehand i was never as public-facing
as i was at the times but
i had written op-eds book reviews and
there was there was already a long
you know google search where you could
find everything that you wanted to if
you if you wanted to dislike me
so from the beginning you know i was
there were certain people who gave me
the cold shoulder
there was i had a feeling like i had to
really overcompensate like i brought in
bubka like every friday i was like i'm a
good person trust me
and also i like bringing in good office
snacks but i felt like there was
something i had to overcome
like i kind of smelled bad right and i
needed to like show them that i was in
good odor
so but you know i'm also like
i'm also a big girl and can i say that
about myself
and and i i like
was so pinching myself that even
so okay what so i'm not cool who cares i
get to work at the new york times
even if you hate it it's still the most
powerful platform in the world
and so that kind of like social
discomfort
that kind of rolled off my back to be
honest with you like
i'm i'm pretty used to that because i'm
i'm often like
kind of on the edge of one group or
another i'm kind of like politically
homeless so i was used to that
which what shifted was when
that kind of
the sense that like my politics were
somewhat heretical
came to justify open bullying of me
including in slack channels with
thousands
of my colleagues so that by the end of
my time there
you know there were like acts and
guillotine emojis being put up next to
my name and next to the name of my boss
that was forced out of the paper
um there were people openly calling for
me to be fired
again in full view of the publisher and
the masthead and everyone else
there were people you know it was and
this had gone on for a long time but
like i would kind of be sitting two
desks away from someone that was
you know hold on sorry to interrupt you
you
they were calling for you to be fired
because what you were sexually harassing
people or like what were you
yeah five foot four woman is a real real
threat
that's what i mean like what were you
doing that people your colleagues are
calling for you to be fired
what i was doing was that i i was
problematic
like think about it this way because
this was like when i first
encountered this view of the world at
columbia university
in the middle east studies department
they
almost to a person pushed the soviet
propaganda line that zionism was racism
okay well if zionism is racism then
zionists are racist
and then it became acceptable to bully
zionists
including in the classroom and it was
exactly the same thing at the new york
times
as the this ideology
kind of hardened and as the sort of
tenets of the new dogma
that laundry list grew ever longer
anyone that didn't ascribe
or conform to every single aspect of
that dogma
was seen as suspicious and i was
suspicious in so many ways i mean
during the metoo movement you know i
wrote this crazy piece that said
you know we should trust women but
verify their claims
crazy
it was it was nuts you know like radical
uh you know during the women you know
during evergreen i had written in
support of bretton heather i
wrote pieces about his pick your topic
like
you know i just didn't conform to
everything
they believed and so what happened
obviously everything in this country and
i think around
the world heat it up in the pandemic and
also
following the murder of george floyd and
the black lives matter movement
and that led to this intense what i
think will be remembered as a kind of
moral panic
inside the paper so that when we ran in
early june god it's almost like to the
day
a year ago an op-ed by republican
senator tom cotton saying that the
national guard should be brought in
to quell violent rioters not peaceful
protests but violent rioters
there was just an absolute con
conflagration at the paper
and 800 people signed this
letter claiming that the peace literally
put their lives in danger
and rather than saying to them
maybe go have a drink or maybe consider
getting a job
that's not in journalism the response
was to praise
people for their moral courage it was to
fire
and reassign my bosses who had brought
me into the paper
and it was to hang out to dry and this
is a story that still needs to be told
my 25 year old colleague as a scapegoat
who was one of seven editors that worked
on that piece who ultimately ended up
leaving
being pushed out and leaving the paper
so like
that to me was a signal event where i
knew wait
if that's how they're going to treat
people that tried to do their job
and tried to take a risk i don't even
think it's a risk but
try to take a risk by running a piece
that other colleagues or our readers
would be challenged by
how could i possibly think that i that
the same thing won't happen to me
and that was when i you know was facing
this choice of
okay i can stay here and keep
you know the most powerful name in news
which is barry weiss of the new york
times
and a lot of people you know really
respond when you say that you're calling
from the times and it's a real
prestigious thing
and and by stay i need to avoid writing
about an ever increasing number of
topics that i think are the real story
in this country
and by an increasing number of topics
give us an example of what you mean by
that
oh just like you know the violence let's
say of the
many of the the protests of this past
summer the idea that they weren't all
peaceful
um the idea i remember trying to
commission
complicated pieces about the really hard
subject of
trans athletes in high school sports
um but but already it had been so
difficult
and took so much energy for me to do my
job which is to bring in pieces that
wouldn't otherwise appear in the paper
and it just took like
the threshold and the bar was so so high
um for you know pieces from people like
you know glenn lowry or thomas
chatterton williams or just pieces that
didn't toe the line
were just so much harder to smuggle
through and by the end of my time
i actually was told not to commission
pieces anymore
because the new system following the tom
cotton debacle and i'm sure it's changed
at this point because it's just totally
unsustainable
was that every editor needed to sign off
on every single piece
and that if anyone raised a red flag
that this piece made them uncomfortable
it wouldn't run so of course that meant
i couldn't do my job and i literally had
an email from then
my then boss saying like why don't you
just write pieces for a while i see that
like i think you should stop
commissioning and then it was like
well why am i here like what's my life
really about what's my career really
about
because this isn't it and that
effectively means that journalism is
dead because the greatest pieces of
journalism
are incendiary they deal with truth they
deal with
dealing with some subject matter that we
are uncomfortable with
we all remember those groundbreaking
pieces of journalism
yeah i mean i i don't want to overstate
this guys because
there's still like not just reporters
but stories that come out of the times
that are unbelievable like i think about
jack nickus's
recent expose of apple in china like
this is one of the things that we have
not
figured out yet how to do and hopefully
this will be the next decade
like podcasts are great newsletters are
great they can do a certain kind of
reporting
but the amount of infrastructure and
support legally and security wise that
you need to go report in a country like
iran
or china sorry like substance can't do
that yet
so like they're still great great
reporters at the times
the problem is is that once the times is
so clearly betraying its values and
other arenas you start to be skeptical
of those stories too which is another
one of the dangers yeah
that's a very good point barry that's
the one thing that nobody in the
alternative media yet
is able to do even very rich people is
the investigative journalism that needs
thousands of man hours and
exactly like journalism journalism is
very expensive and it is a real skill
and the great thing about it though is
that it's not a skill that requires a
college degree
like you all you need to do to be a
great journalist is to learn the skill
of
dropping into strange places and
learning how to talk to people
one of the things i remember suggesting
to the publisher of the times when
way before all of this was happening
years before i suggested two things
um because you know they knew that i was
getting bullied and
they were at first you know very
sympathetic about it but ultimately did
nothing
one thing i suggested was ban all new
york times reporters from twitter
try it for six months try for six months
and see how that affects
their reporting the second thing i said
was
hire make an explicit policy that you
will not hire people
from any elite institutions or or the
coasts
hire people from the middle of the
country that do not have college degrees
and see how that changes you know your
ability to fulfill your mission
you know i don't think they took me up
like i'm sure those two ideas went down
brilliantly barry i can just say
they did yes but listen uh we got to let
you go
uh it's been really great chatting with
you i i
i've really enjoyed it i'm sure francis
has as well and i know our audience will
have enjoyed it
uh we've got one final question for you
which we ask all of our guests which is
what is the one thing that we're not
talking about that we really should be
oh
i think we're not talking enough about
sex
speak for yourself i i don't know if you
guys have seen but there was this crazy
chart that came out
a few months ago that showed that and
this was before
covet that the percentage of men in
america between the ages of 18 and 24
who hadn't had sex in the previous year
i think
was 30
that's wild to me and that's a story
that i feel like has not been told
and has incredible cultural and
political ramifications so
i'll be looking at it's a story that's
very much on my radar
um because the question of like are we
turning into japan i think is
and what are the implications of that i
think are a really interesting one
the ladies of trigonometry you've got a
job to do
barry listen it's been an absolute
pleasure chatting with you uh
you're i am so looking forward to your
new podcast honestly with barry
it's going to be great i'm going to tell
people a little bit about i read the
press release and you just
absolutely nailed what i think the
moment needs so tell everybody
why you decide to start a podcast and
where else people can find you online
because every because the world needs
another podcast absolutely
i decided to start a podcast because i
feel like the most
interesting and searching and authentic
conversations
in our lives no longer happen in public
they happen in private
and i want to take what's happening on
my whatsapp and signal chats
and have those conversations out loud
and i want to tell the stories
that the legacy press is overlooking um
and tell them in a way that promotes
empathy and understanding rather than
polarization so
the first episode is i'm incredibly
proud of it it's
it's not an interview with a famous
celebrity
it's an interview with a palestinian
business owner in minneapolis named
majdiwadi
and the public shaming and the boycott
of his business
that he lived through and what his story
says
about the direction that the country's
heading in and the way that he
articulates
the kind of foundational values that
we've been talking about
i think will really really move people
that sounds incredible i'm going to go
and listen to it
and so we're like barry thank you so
much for coming on the show
if people want to find you on social
media etc etc where is the best place to
do that
they can find me twitter at barry weiss
they can subscribe to my newsletter
barryweiss.substack.com calm
and go look up honestly with barry weiss
fantastic thank you so much barry for
your time and thank you guys for
watching
we will be back very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all of them go out at 7pm uk
time take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below